[music]
>> As-salamu alaykum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh.
How was the experience?
For most of it may have been the first
time you're doing a prepared speech.
How was the experience?
Who gave a prepared speech for the first
time on the stage? Prepared speech, not
introduction.
Prepared speech, raise your hand.
Prepared speech.
Up or down?
1 2 3 4 5 6. Six people gave for the
first time prepared speech.
And 13 people
have given prepared speech before,
whether once, twice, 10 times, 100
times, some 900 times.
I have my own calculation of giving
marks, we'll discuss that inshallah on
the third day of the training day after
tomorrow, and I'll show you how I give
marks. But normally, if I'm judging a
person who's not a professional speaker,
then the marking system is different.
On the higher level it matches. Why I
give marks for the dress code, for the
this, telling you inshallah day after
tomorrow. And by default,
an average person who knows English
comes on the stage should get minimum
30.
How much?
If you know the English well,
he should minimum get 30 out of 100 by
default.
And because we have interviewed and
brother Kaleem has spent his time
interviewing, the English should be good
and passion. So minimum anyone comes on
the stage, the average should be 40.
Thinking you're coming for the first
time.
If you have come before,
then you should get 40, 50, 60, 70,
80. But if you get 70 of this rating
and 70 of the end rating, there is a
difference because there the rating will
be professional. This rating that you're
coming
but the higher you go it becomes more
professional. If you get an average
person who knows English and comes on
the stage, and if I judge,
if 10 people come, you add up all 10
marks and divide by 10, the answer would
be
30 because
there's something like
called as pronunciation.
He has to get marks.
He has to get six as a
All of you have been selected. So by
default you have to get even if you
don't know public speaking skills.
You are wearing good clothes, by default
you have to get marks out of five.
By default.
So an average person, if none of you
ever spoke on the stage,
an average person who knows English
comes on the stage should get 30.
An average person who has been
interviewed by Kaleem and agreeing none
of you have ever come on the stage
should get 40.
The result is
that three of
you amongst you out of 20
did get below 30.
I won't spell out.
Majority came between 30 and got below
40.
That means what our expectation was
only
Sorry, not three, four. Four people got
below 30.
1 2 3 4 5 6.
>> [snorts]
>> Six
of the people got above 40. Expectation
was that everyone should have above 40.
And those have come on the stage should
get actually more than 50.
Out of those who got above 40,
out of six,
only two got above 50.
Only two.
And
fortunately or unfortunately,
though I know that
I was told that about 14 people How many
14 people came on the stage? How many
did not come on the stage? Six, no?
How many did not come on the stage?
Can you raise your hand?
Before with the prepared speech.
Prepared speech. 1 2 3 4 5 6. So if you
come you should get 40.
Because you're not prepared. Those who
have a prepared speech who have done and
are experienced should get more marks.
Maybe you have experience but you don't
know the techniques. You may have spoken
100 times on the stage.
And you may be thinking it's very good.
But with technique it will be multiple
times better. Only two of the people got
more than
60.
Actually they got more than 70.
The reason is that because both happened
to be
from the school Islamic International
School
where we train people to give speeches
from the age of four. So only two
of the participants crossed.
They're supposed to cross 60, but they
crossed 70.
And both fortunately or unfortunately
happened to be from the Islamic
International School.
The remaining four
got between 40 and 45.
40 and 45 means
because you have been interviewed,
fine, if you have been interviewed you
have to get minimum 40 because
brother Kaleem saw the English should be
good, the passion should be there.
Inshallah on the last day
of this course, we will show you the
comparison between the first day and the
last day.
It's good news and bad news both.
Bad news that if you have been on the
stage so many times and you didn't know
public speaking skills, if you have done
this training maybe before, you would
have been multiple times better. The
good news is better late than never.
So four people got between 40 and 45.
Two people got above 70.
But after
70 every mark is important.
From 80 to 81 is more difficult than 10
to 60.
From 80 to 81 marks is more difficult
than 10 to 60.
From 81 to 82 is more difficult. From 82
83 is more difficult. Inshallah, your
speeches have been recorded.
Last day we will show you both your
speeches. First day and last day. And
you yourself can judge.
There has to be a difference
in all of you, including those who have
scored above 70.
I will not tell how much they scored.
It will be a difference.
But naturally that time my marking would
be a different level.
For anyone to come on Peace TV a minimum
the speaker should have 60 marks.
We do have speakers less than 60 if she
has some other qualification.
So inshallah, I look forward for the
next
31 days.
Which we'll discuss in detail
inshallah from the next day, that's day
after tomorrow, the third day of the
training program. But overall,
it was good that people from different
walks of life, some have come the first
time, some have been trainers, some have
been public speakers for years together.
And
some have been trainers for
sessions.
Trainers in training other people, and
the effectiveness of the skill you'll
come to know when we do the technique
inshallah day after tomorrow. And once
you reach a high level,
anything you do,
except for few things, no problem. Even
if you break the rules,
that is when you reach a level.
When you reach a level, then you can
break your rules and yet be effective,
but that will come later on. First,
come to a certain level.
So inshallah when we do the techniques
day after tomorrow, you yourself will
realize
what you did, what you should not have
done, and what you should do inshallah
in future.
We'll have a short break.
We'll have for 20 minutes, so then we
come back fast. And today we are going
to have the extended session which is
mentioned in advance, that some days we
may have the extended session, and the
extended session mainly is not because
we are delayed today, it is mainly
because yesterday we missed a session
introduction
to the Dawah training program which we
shall do immediately after the break.
Inshallah I'll try and make it short.
After that, we will have the session
on techniques
of giving lectures on the Quran.
If time permits we will also do the
revision of the first 25 surahs of the
Quran. If time doesn't permit we'll have
the break, Maghrib salah, and then do
the revision of the Quranic surahs, and
then the revision of the Quranic verses.
Inshallah.
Brother Omar Yusuf from Sri Lanka.
My dear respected elders and brothers in
Islam, I would like to speak about
understanding the Quran, inshallah
ta'ala.
So,
the most amazing and the most sacred of
scriptures and the sacred of words in
the surface of the earth is
the book of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
and every one of us know about this.
But unfortunately and sadly,
many Muslims, majority of the Muslims,
don't understand the Quran.
Don't understand the Quran.
So, Arabic has turned out to become the
one and only language on the surface of
the earth
where people don't understand the Quran
and they
learn it only to read the Quran,
subhanallah.
Will you ever take out a newspaper in
the morning only to read without
understanding the newspaper?
No, but we need to understand the
newspaper. Just like that, we need to
understand the words of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala before we attempt to read it.
My beloved brothers and elders in Islam,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says in the
Quran, Surah Muhammad, chapter number
47, verse number 24. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala says, "Afala yatadabbarunal Quran
am ala qulubin aqfaluha?" In fact, Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala asks you, "Will you
not ponder upon the Quran? Or your
hearts are locked?"
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala did not say
"yaqra'un". Allah did not use the word
"read". Allah used the word
"yatadabbarun", ponder or reflect to
understand.
My beloved brothers and elders in Islam,
Ali radiyallahu anhu, the famous great
person, he said,
"La fa'idata fi qira'atin laysa fiha
tadabbur." There is no benefit in a
recitation where there is no pondering
and reflecting. My beloved brothers and
elders in Islam, I would say, "Even if
you are to spend a half of your life in
search of the understanding of the
Quran, I would say it is a worthy
project because you are going to spend
your rest of your life in the
understanding of the Quran and with
consciousness of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala." My beloved brothers and elders
in Islam, as that is, I call upon all of
you, just as how you would learn a
language for a job that you are urged
called for, I would request you to learn
the words of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala,
understand the words of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala, learn the language to learn
the words of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
That would be more beneficial for all of
us. Wa akhiru da'wana alhamdulillah
rabbil alamin.
Inshallah, we'll go for a break now
and we'll resume inshallah at 5:00 p.m.
sharp, inshallah. So, you can finish
with your asr prayers and your tea break
and be back
at least 5 minutes before 5:00,
inshallah. Assalam alaykum.
>> [music]
[music]